et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Laurent jacobelli bonjour merci d'être
avec nous député de la Moselle
porte-parole du rassemblement national
vous le serez toujours sous la
présidence de jardin Bardella
il le fera une conférence de presse
mercredi pour dévoiler son nouvel
organigramme voilà vous souhaitez
toujours être bien sûr
du groupe lesbra bonjour Fabrice bonjour
Laurent on va évidemment parler de votre
partie et on est quatre jours après ça a
été incident cette polémique déclenchée
par les propos de votre député Grégoire
de Fournas qui a dit je le rappelle
qu'il retourne en Afrique à l'occasion
d'une question d'un député de la France
insoumise est-ce que quatre jours après
vous dites il aurait dû s'abstenir de
telles propos il aurait dû s'abstenir de
cette invective je pense que si
quelqu'un avait dû s'abstenir c'est à la
fois les membres du gouvernement de se
prononcer c'est l'opposition et les
filles parce qu'aujourd'hui les faits
sont très claires il n'y a pas eu de
propos racis il n'y a pas eu d'injures
d'un député envers un député il y a eu
une analyse politique d'une situation et
imaginez que au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale qui est le cœur battant de
notre démocratie et de la libre
expression on ne puisse pas avoir une
autre vision de l'immigration que celle
du gouvernement et bien c'est très grave
c'est pas sur un débat de fond Laurent
jacobello on est sur une invective qu'il
retourne en Afrique est-ce que c'est une
manière de le dire mais il y a un débat
de fond derrière est-ce qu'on une
immigration incontrôlée clandestine
est-ce que on va vers une régularisation
massive est-ce qu'on continue à
subventionner des organisations qui vont
chercher les migrants en Afrique pour
les amener en France c'est une vraie
question de fond après vous parlez d'un
objectif vous êtes sur une chaîne
parlementaire vous connaissez la vie
parlementaire et vous savez très bien
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale il y a des
investitives en permanence moi je le
regrette vous voyez c'est pas ma vision
de voir le débat d'une manière générale
mais c'est le jeu à l'Assemblée
nationale et je vais vous dire si à
chaque fois qu'il y avait une invective
le député était renvoyé dans ses pénates
je crois qu'aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
nationale on serait trois quatre à
débattre donc il y a un moment il peut
pas y avoir deux poids de mesure il peut
pas y avoir des sanctions très lourdes
dès qu'on a les tickets de rassemblement
national et une immunité totale pour les
autres c'est une sanction politique elle
est clairement politique et je vais être
très clair quand un député de la
majorité se lève et fait le salut nazi
quand nous parlons lui il a un rappel à
l'ordre il est pas sanctionné plus
durement quand des députés de la France
insoumises nous insultent nous traitent
de fascistes ils n'ont même pas eux de
rappel à l'ordre et quand on émet une
opinion sur l'immigration notre député
est renvoyé chez lui franchement oui il
y a de poids de mesure et je crois que
les Français ne sont pas durs en
jacobelli cet incident a quand même
ramené sur la table cette éternelle
question de le Front national devenu
rassemblement national est-il en partie
raciste clairement NON et d'ailleurs le
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale qui a
pris une décision contre les députés
Grégoire de fonas n'a pas retenu le
motif de racisme qui était celui que
certains autres députés voulaient lui
voir assainer il n'a même pas retenu ce
bureau l'insulte envers un autre député
il a juste retenu la création d'un
tumulte vous vous rendez compte qu'on a
un député qui est privé d'assemblée
nationale pendant 15 jours pour tumulte
il y en a tous les jours depuis surtout
que la France insoumise siège en nombre
à l'Assemblée nationale et pour autant
leur député ne sont pas condamnés ni
même sanctionné donc vous voyez bien
qu'il y a un de poids de mesure vous
voyez bien que tout cela tombe et puis
il y a une surexploitation qui est
honteuse et pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a
cette exploitation parce que notamment
le gouvernement refuse qu'on fasse le
triste bilan de sa politique
d'immigration le bilan en termes
sécuritaire le bilan en termes
économique le Milan en termes d'identité
c'est une catastrophe c'est un échec et
c'est même pire que les gouvernements
précédents et ça je crois qu'il n'a pas
envie qu'on en parle de la politique
d'immigration mais sur la pour finir sur
la gestion de cet événement vous pensez
qu'il y a le brune pivée la présidente
de l'Assemblée elle a pas bien géré cet
événement
écoutez c'est ma présidente de fait je
j'ai une forme de devoir de réserve en
tout cas il y a une incohérence
flagrante retenir comme seul motif le
tumulte et donner la plus forte sanction
c'est que la deuxième fois depuis des
décennies qu'elle est donnée il y a
quelque chose qui va pas effectivement
soit à la CD à la panique soit à la
céder la pression ce sont sa manière de
gérer parce que Sébastien Chenu hier il
a dit que lui s'il avait été comme il
était votre vice-président tout à fait
que lui s'il avait été au perchoir il
aura arrêté de même la séance de
questions d'actualité parce que c'est
pas possible de la tenir il aurait réuni
les présidents comme la fille à elle
brune pivée la seule chose c'est qu'il
n'aurait pas demandé de sanctions donc
lui reconnaît qu'elle a bien géré
finalement
jusqu'au moment de la décision finale où
on voit bien qu'elle a été prise en étau
entre une pression très forte pour
sanctionner Grégoire de Fournas sur le
principe rien de qui de qui écoutez
clairement j'ai l'impression que votre
adversaire dans tout ça c'est la
majorité sortante Renaissance ou c'est
insoumise non mais je crois que la
pression elle vient de de la majorité
sortante que la France insoumise face le
barouf habituel qu'il monte sur la table
qui tape dans des casseroles et qui
sautent sur place on a l'habitude voilà
des adultes resteront toujours des
addistes en revanche que le gouvernement
prenne cette attitude que monsieur
Clément beau ministre disent que
l'ennemi public numéro 1 en français le
rassemblement national pour le moment où
nous sommes victimes de l'islamisation
du communautarisme de violence dans
sauvagement et bien tout ça montre bien
qu'il y a une volonté
c'était le rassemblement national je
crois qu'il a dit numéro 1 mais on voit
bien qu'il y a derrière une volonté
politique d'un gouvernement qui commence
à à paniquer clairement et de voir que
nous sommes la première fois c'est force
d'opposition et une force solide qui pas
se rapproche du pouvoir officiellement
tout le monde défend dans vos rangs
Grégoire de Fournas est-ce que en
interne ça a pas un peu tangué est-ce
que Marine Le Pen n'a pas ne sait pas un
peu énervé sur cette question c'est l'a
pas un peu agacé alors ça vous lui
demandez je ne sais pas en tout cas elle
a réagi en président de deux groupes
responsables nous avons voulu établir
les faits les faits ont été clairement
établis il n'y a pas eu d'insultes
racistes s'il y avait eu un filtre
raciste je ne doute pas une seconde
connaissant Marine Le Pen qu'elle aurait
pris les mesures qui s'imposaient mais
on ne va pas s'en prendre à un député
parce que la meute a déclaré qu'il
fallait s'en prendre à lui un dernier
mot puisque Bruno Retailleau a réagit
également comme beaucoup de politiques
qui dit personne ne peut considérer
comme racisme le fait de réclamer le
retour des clandestins car si tel est le
cas l'idée même d'exécuter d'exécuter
assez racistes plus aucune expulsion
n'est possible comment vous réagissez à
ça
moi je me permets pas de faire la
gérance chez les républicains mais c'est
exactement ça la vérité et d'ailleurs il
est pas le seul à dire même en dehors de
nos grands ce que dit le député du
rassemblement national
avec sa façon de parler et dans un cadre
bien précis qui sont les questions au
Gouvernement et dont on connaît un peu
le jeu des questions-réponses il dit
quoi il dit aujourd'hui en France il y a
un droit il y a une loi cette loi n'est
plus respectée est-ce que simplement
dire il faut respecter la loi on
renvoyant les migrants clandestins chez
eux est-ce que c'est raciste non c'est
simplement faire respecter les textes et
au cœur de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
normal puisque c'est là qu'on vote ses
lois et honnêtement cette espèce de
tartufferie ambiante elle est un peu
gênante je pense que il suffit de
regarder les images d'ailleurs quand le
député en question de la France
insoumise entend les paroles il répond
avec un sourire mais non mais pas du
tout comme je viens de le faire c'est à
dire qu'il répond sur la gestion de la
migration il ne répond pas du tout comme
s'il venait de se faire insulter il
suffit de regarder les images pour voir
qu'il y a une manipulation énorme
derrière les Français je le répète ne
sont pas dupe congrès oui quand même
quelques réactions optimaux sur les pas
contents notamment Steve brivois brivois
qui a été l'un des
pour la retraite à 60 ans pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt il est
pour moi je vous le dis en tout cas il
est pour que le gouvernement incite aux
augmentations de salaire sous avec
derrière des dégrèvements de charge
sociale fiscal hop patronales pardon je
vais y arriver pour les pour les ceux
qui augmentent les salaires mais pour
répondre à votre question vous dit vous
me parlez des mécontents est-ce qu'on
peut d'abord parler des gens qui sont
contents 85 % des adhérents ont voté
pour Jordan Bardella Louis Aliot qui a
mené une belle campagne qui a été
extrêmement fair-play a tenu un très
beau discours où il a dit puisque Jordan
Bardella la confiance et les électeurs
il a ma confiance voilà la Concorde
générale il y a deux personnes ou trois
personnes qui n'ont pas obtenu les
postes qu'il voulait
ils sont irrités pour ça ils les ont une
forme de d'aigreur de rancoeur espérons
que ça soit passager il nous ait tous
arrivé dans notre vie politique d'avoir
des bonnes et des mauvaises nouvelles
quand c'est pas une question de fond
pour vous c'est pas une interrogation
sur la ligne je crois qu'il y a de la
part des personnes que vous avez cité
une inimitié pour Jordan Bardella
personnel il y a pas de question de fond
et c'est pas avec deux personnes qu'on
fait une ligne politique voilà on entend
plus du tout parler de Marion maréchal
qui a quand même très proche de la
famille du parti même si elle est partie
avec Zemmour est-ce que le fait que vous
disiez Jordan Bardella Marine Le Pen a
voulu les choses comme ça est-ce que
c'est une façon aussi de faire oublier
Marion maréchal qui était l'avenir du de
vos idées alors sans vouloir faire
offense à Marion maréchal Le Pen elle
elle a décidé de s'éloigner du mouvement
elle a décidé de rejoindre Renaissance
avec Éric Zemmour c'est son choix on ne
lui a pas demandé de le faire
j'ai dit comment vous voyez qu'elle
lapsus mais souvent d'ailleurs
ça c'est un peu loin quand même on peut
se demander si n'était pas un peu piloté
par l'autre pour essayer de nous nuire
la question reste se poser mais en tout
cas elle s'est éloignée de notre
mouvement c'est son choix personne ne
l'a écarté j'ai pas d'autres
commentaires à faire je pense que jamais
été resté avec nous qu'elle avait
travaillé en comme un accord avec
l'ensemble des cadres et des adhérents
ce serait très bien passé elle a choisi
une autre voie dont acte j'ai
l'impression que c'était une voie sans
issue mais ça c'est son son choix à elle
est-ce que vous avez la garantie et le
souhait vous allez nous dire que Jordan
Bardella ne se rapprochera pas d'Éric
Zemmour il a été très clair Jordan
Bardella ne veut pas se rapprocher d'un
parti il veut pas se rapprocher de tel
ou tel figure politique jardin Bardella
il veut rassembler voilà mais rassemblée
pour se rassembler il faut bien se
rapprocher de loin on va parler aux
électeurs on va parler aux électeurs de
droit de gauche à ceux qui ne sont pas
encore encarté j'allais dire et on va
leur dire voilà on a un beau projet pour
la France tous ceux qui aiment ce pays
qui voient que le pays va dans le mur
gérer comme il est aujourd'hui tous ceux
qui ne vendent pas de la mondialisation
tous ceux qui veulent et qui ne veulent
pas de l'immigration massive tous ceux
qui ne veulent pas de la casse sociale
de nous rejoindre pour un beau projet
républicain qui va amener à l'alternance
en 2027 et pour ça nous allons parler à
tout le monde mais on va pas faire des
petits accords derrière boutique avec
des gens qui important à nous taper
dessus ou qui ne veulent pas voter avec
nous tout simplement est-ce que vous
recherchez toujours ce qu'on appelle la
normalisation du parti alors j'ai
l'impression d'être très normal je vais
vous rassurer j'ai l'impression que nos
électeurs sont très normaux et j'ai
l'impression que quand on vote
rassemblement national on reste normal
après donc ce terme franchement m'étonne
nous sommes un parti républicain nous
avons des représentants dans les
municipalités dans les départements dans
les régions maintenant massivement à
l'Assemblée nationale nous aurons demain
je le crois les plus hautes
responsabilités nous sommes un parti
normal épousez vous la question quand on
essaye d'écarter quelqu'un de l'arc
républicain comme ils disent c'est
probablement parce que sur les arguments
on a plus grand chose à nous opposer sur
le terme de l'immigration cette Français
sur 10 sont d'accord avec nous sur le
laxisme judiciaire cette Français sur 10
sont d'accord avec nous sur la réforme
des retraites une majorité de Français
sont d'accord avec nous pour ne pas la
faire vous voyez quand on a gagné la
bataille des idées bien en face quand il
y a une faiblesse des arguments il y a
l'insulte ou les cas donc vous ne la
recherchez pas mais nous sommes normaux
c'est clair quelle place aura Marine Le
Pen dans ce parti samedi elle a dit
qu'elle mobilisé et casserai là où la
cause nationale a besoin d'elle ce sont
ces mots quelle place elle va occuper
elle va avoir une place prépondérante
Marine Le Pen est la présidente du
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale elle est
je crois reconnu comme la principale
opposante à Emmanuel Macron et elle est
la deuxième personnalité politique
préférée des français donc clairement
elle a un rôle central à jouer pendant
toute cette campagne j'ai parlé mais
pendant toute cette campagne j'ai parlé
d'un duo voilà le duo Jordan marine et
je crois que c'est ce que nous allons
continuer à faire ce duo il fonctionne
bien il marche bien marine comme Jordan
sont très soutenus très aimés de la part
des cadres des adhérents ils sont
reconnus comme des personnalités
publiques efficaces et le premier plan
continuons comme ça ça marche très bien
l'idée pas de dire voilà c'est elle est
numéro un machin elle elle a une place à
part dans le cœur des Français et des
adhérents et elle va la garder
2027 j'ai le souhait de tout mon coeur
et nous sommes nombreux à souhaiter oui
il l'a dit d'ailleurs il l'a dit la
maman la décision lui appartient on
pensait pas que l'élève va dépasser le
maître
Marine Le Pen elle a été elle a dit
qu'il lui devait tout mais bien sûr
qu'il lui doit énormément maintenant je
vais vous dire pour voir Jordan
travailler je pense que sa position
aujourd'hui de président du
Rassemblement national il la doit à son
charisme à sa capacité de défendre nos
idées et à son sens de l'organisation
aussi il a fait ses preuves donc je
pense que maintenant il faut se détacher
de cette vision
on va dire l'un pilote l'autre je ne
sais pas quoi je parle vraiment d'un
tandem et si je le fais c'est que je
crois que c'est vraiment la réalité
on va parler de la dissolution alors ce
weekend on a beaucoup parlé des
solutions personne sait d'où ça vient
Renaissance aurait évoqué la possibilité
de mettre un peu d'argent de côté pour
dans l'éventualité d'une dissolution
voulue par le président de la République
qui estime le plus pouvoir gouverner
est-ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
nouvelle oui a priori ah écoutez il y a
aujourd'hui une assemblée qui a été élue
ce qui serait logique c'est qu'elle est
à son terme maintenant si le président
de la République parce ce qu'il veut
faire peur aux républicains clairement
on va dire on va dire les choses il veut
accélérer la fusion Renaissance cette
fois je me suis pas trompé avec les
républicains et donc il leur dit grosso
modo si vous le faites pas je dissous et
donc les républicains sont morts ce qui
est sûrement probablement vrai
parce que si le président de la
République voulait vraiment dissoudre
dans les semaines qui viennent il ne
l'aurait pas dit je vais vous dire pour
prendre ses adversaires de cours
maintenant s'il le fait on est prêt
voilà on est prêt on a les candidats on
a le programme
dans les 577 circonscription prêt à
repartir en campagne on est prêt on est
prêt et je vais vous dire c'est pas 89
députés qu'on aura c'est 150 200
députants donc c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour répondre à la question c'est pas
une bonne si ça se fait c'est une bonne
nouvelle si ça se fait nous relèverons
le défi et ce défi où gagneront et vous
représenterez tous vos candidats y
compris Grégoire de Fornas
la commission d'investiture qui sera
nommée mercredi qui décidera et pour
l'instant elle n'est pas nommée
je ne vois pas de raison pour lesquelles
il ne le seraient pas Olivier Vérand lui
dit que les Français ne souhaitent pas
l'addition qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors ça c'est un indice hein d'ailleurs
pour répondre à votre question parce que
quand Olivier vérandit quelque chose en
général c'est l'inverse qui se passe
rappelez-vous les masques rappelez-vous
l'ensemble des mesures qu'il a prononcé
donc si Olivier vérandit qu'il n'y a pas
de dissolution je pense qu'il faut qu'on
s'y prenne juste puisque vous vous dites
pourquoi vous dites que vous aurez 200
députés il y a un sondage hier qui est
paru dans le JDD il faut qu'il dit que
vous avez un bon gagnant un peu plus de
1% des voix en cas de dissolution ça
fait pas 200 députés parce que si vous
prenez la totalité des députés de chez
nous des candidats pardon qui ont fait
entre 48 et 50%
et qui n'ont pas franchi la marche cette
fois-là il pourrait la franchir et puis
il y a une dynamique aussi et ne
l'oublions pas ça veut dire que parce
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de duels entre le
rassemblement national et la nuque ça
veut dire que vous estimez que la nuque
est affaibliée que dans ces duels cette
fois vous gagner je pense que les
électeurs de la nupesse pour certains
ceux qui sont de la gauche républicaine
ceux qui sont d'une gauche raisonnable
ne veulent pas de ce cirque ne veulent
pas de ces insultes permanentes ne
veulent pas de cette attitude anti
républicaine ils sont gênés de voir
parfois des députés de la nups
manifestée avec d'autres gens très peu
fréquentables je pense que ces gens-là
ne seront pas l'erreur une deuxième fois
le projet de loi immigration Gérald
Darmanin a présenté les grandes lignes
de son futur texte arrivera au Parlement
d'abord au Sénat en début 2023 est-ce
que vous pourriez le voter nous verrons
vous savez nous on a une doctrine très
claire quand nous arrive un texte on lit
s'il est bon le vote si les moyens ont
l'amende si les mauvais on le rejette
clairement nous aurons des propositions
à faire vous le savez sur le
regroupement familial sur le droit du
sol sur les aides sociales aux étrangers
sur le contrôle aux frontières nous
avons beaucoup de propositions à faire
donc nous étudierons le projet de
Monsieur Dharma maîtresse honnêtement
les premiers signes qui nous sont donnés
sont un peu perturbants d'abord l'homme
qui a atteint le plus faible taux de
retour
d'étrangers frappé doc qtf obligation de
quitter le territoire français c'est
Gérard Darmanin et Gérald Darmanin et
c'est lui qui nous dit qu'il va aller
faire respecter il y a une forme de
paradoxe il est le ministre de
l'Intérieur du gouvernement qui a
accueilli le plus de migrants légaux
depuis Sarkozy voilà Sarkozy était à peu
près 180000 par an aujourd'hui c'est
272000 si on ne prend que les titres de
séjour donc ils sont probablement les
plus mal placés pour jouer la fermeté
sur l'immigration donc
est-ce que est-ce que ce qu'il en a
présenté en tout cas ça vous convient
non qu'est-ce qui vous convient pas
d'abord la régularisation alors c'est
plus une régularisation d'abord on y
comprend rien mais des clandestins qui
travaillent clandestinement c'est non on
va être une régularisation c'est un
titre de séjour d'un an pour ceux qui
travaillent dans des métiers en temps
une semaine avec Monsieur du stop il
parlait de régularisation donc il va
falloir qu'ils se mettent d'accord entre
eux mais déjà c'est pas très bon signe
mais honnêtement quand il y a 5,4
millions de chômeurs en France quand il
y a des salaires trop faibles pour
permettre à des gens qui travaillent de
vivre la première solution c'est
d'augmenter les salaires d'inciter à
l'augmentation des salaires pour que les
gens qui sont légalement en France et
surtout a priori a fortiori qui sont
Français puissent obtenir un travail
l'idéal ce sont des gens qui occupent
déjà des postes illégalement donc quand
on occupe un poste illégalement il faut
être expulsé et pas régulariser oui mais
sauf que ce sont des gens dont les
patrons ont besoin puisque c'est des
postes qui n'arrivent pas à pourvoir
avec des Français je vais vous citer un
exemple parce que là vous faites
abstraction quand même de la
problématique du recrutement actuels
sont confrontés
peut-être pas tous mais en tout cas il y
a des secteurs en tension il faut le
dire vous avez beaucoup plus qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé au Royaume-Uni au
Royaume-Uni il y a quelques mois il y a
eu une politique d'immigration et de
d'autorisation de d'immigration de
travail beaucoup plus stricte qu'avant
les règles ont changé qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé chez les restaurateurs et
bien puisqu'il ne pouvait plus employer
de main d'oeuvre immigré ils ont
augmenté les salaires à peu près en
dessous de 10% pour attirer des des
travailleurs britanniques ça a marché
pourquoi est-ce que ça marcherait pas en
France si comme nous le proposons les
patrons qui augmentent de 10% les
salaires sont exonérés de charges
patronales sur ces 10%, on va créer une
dynamique à l'emploi ce qui n'est plus
tolérable aujourd'hui c'est que des
Français qui travaille n'est pas assez
finalement pour vivre j'allais dire
dignement simplement et qu'on a recours
à une main d'oeuvre étrangère qui est
prête à tout accepter parce qu'elle est
en situation irrégulière parce que chez
elle évidemment il y a la misère et donc
on est en train de créer un esclavagisme
moderne on est en train de crier un
événement par le bas des salaires est-ce
que c'est acceptable est-ce qu'on veut
une France qui perd à la fois son
identité et ses valeurs sociales
est essentiellement lié à la question
des salaires je le pense et de formation
je veux dire pareil en France on a un
vrai problème de formation moi dans ma
région le Grand Est on va fermer des
lycées professionnels au moment où on a
besoin de plus en plus de gens qui ont
des technicités et des savoir-faire liés
à des secteurs en tension tout cela n'a
pas de sens aujourd'hui entre le moment
où on décide une formation et où elle
s'applique dans des secteurs en tension
il se passe 5 à 10 ans c'est pas normal
donc là aussi il y a du travail vous
avez raison de le dire la question elle
est plus large que la seule question de
l'augmentation des salaires ou de
l'immigration mais en tout cas ce texte
en tout cas tel qu'il est présenté après
on a je suis pas devin j'attends de lire
avant de me prononcer
dans l'état actuel de ce qu'on entend
c'est brouillon et et c'est probablement
pas assez documenté et c'est même un peu
faibles sur certains domaines donc en
l'état actuel ça semble peu probable
qu'on le vote mais nous verrons bien
vous avez vu ce que dit Gérard Darmanin
qui dit le rassemblement national vie
des problèmes quand on arrive à les
résoudre il n'a plus de carburant
politique oui monsieur Darmanin je crois
et dans l'agitation permanente dans la
com permanente l'homme qui ne fait pas
respecter les
occultés
absolument pas il y a aucune mesure et
d'ailleurs monsieur Darmanin lui dit
lui-même de recours possibles de
possibilités de recours mais que les
hôpitaux soient plus facilement
il va même créer des fichiers mais une
fois qu'il aura son petit fichier une
fois qu'il aura moins de recours
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire quand il faudra
expulser quelqu'un parce qu'aujourd'hui
le problème c'est qu'il y en a des
occupés F qui sont prononcés et même à
l'appel le problème c'est qu'il n'y a
que 5,6% de ces au qtf qui ont été
réalisés lors du premier semestre 2021
dernière
sorte de la vie impossible ce sont ces
mots mais attendez le travail du
ministre de l'intérieur n'est pas de
s'entendre à des profs gens le travail
est de faire respecter la loi donc c'est
ce même homme qui veut rendre leur vie
impossible est incapable de les expulser
donc à ce moment-là ce qu'il fait c'est
qu'il prend un billet d'avion il va à
Alger il demande à voir son homologue et
il dit maintenant c'est très simple si
vous reprenez pas vos ressortissants qui
sont sous le coup d'une autre qtf les
visas c'est fini les économiques c'est
fini les contrats et les contrats que
nos entreprises ont passé on les revoit
un par un et je peux vous assurer que le
lendemain matin les occultés FS sont à
respecter voilà ce qu'on attend d'un
ministre de l'intérieur c'est de
l'action c'est pas de l'agitation un
dernier mot sur le pouvoir d'achat
évidemment c'est un sujet important
Bruno Le Maire hier a défendu le
dividende salarié c'est une promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron il veut une convention
de la majorité sur le partage de la
valeur et qui pourrait déboucher sur une
proposition de loi est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à ça tout ce qui va dans le
sens du pouvoir d'achat et de
l'alimentation des salaires sera étudié
avait bienveillance de notre part mais
s'ils ont enfin pris l'ampleur la mesure
de l'ampleur du désastre du pouvoir
d'achat aujourd'hui alors qu'ils
prennent toutes les mesures qu'ils
prennent des mesures aussi sur la TVA
nous on propose avec Marine Le Pen et
notre groupe une TVA à 0% sur les
produits de première nécessité qu'il
baisse la TVA sur les énergies de 20% à
5 et demi pour cent qu'il aide les les
veuves des anciens combattants qui le
fassent enfin le travail c'est pas avec
des mesures c'est pas avec des chèques
c'est pas avec des conventions
citoyennes qu'ils rêvera les choses
c'est avec de la volonté et honnêtement
cette volonté on ne sent pas qu'il l'est
beaucoup Michel édou Leclerc avait posé
la question des hausses de prix
suspectes dans la grande distribution
suite à ses propos vous aviez demandé
une commission d'enquête Bruno Le Maire
a dit hier que le rapport de Bercy
disait qu'il n'y avait pas de profiteur
est-ce que du coup cette commission
d'enquête est encore pertinente je n'ai
aucune confiance dans la parole de
Monsieur le Maire il faut une commission
d'enquête pour vérifier c'est vrai ou
pas vrai oui donc Monsieur le Maire a
commandé lui-même à ses équipes par
rapport qui disent qu'il voulait qu'ils
disent honnêtement ça s'appelle de
l'entre-soi on a aujourd'hui la chance
en France d'avoir un parlement qui peut
agir faire des commissions d'enquête et
avec des députés de la majorité et de
l'opposition qui est un travail sérieux
faisons-le parce que honnêtement allez
expliquer aux Français qui payent 20 à
30% plus cher certains produits de
l'alimentation à cause d'une guerre en
Ukraine honnêtement ils ont parfois du
mal à faire le lien et je les comprends
dernière question
des républicains mais quand même une
petite question l'un des candidats à la
présidence Aurélien Pradier préconise le
retour de l'uniforme à l'école vous
auriez pu faire cette proposition nous
l'avons faites voilà un de nos députés
écrit une proposition de loi en ce sens
donc je vois que Monsieur Pradier
cellier il s'est même s'inspirer de
notre travail je crois que ça s'arrête
là non je vais pas m'ingérer dans le
dans la vie des républicains mais je
pense qu'il y a un moment il faut que
les électeurs comprennent que
nous sommes dans une situation
paradoxale sur le terrain pendant les
élections ils parlent comme nous une
fois élu ils allégent avec Emmanuel
Macron il y a un moment il faut qu'il
sorte de cette dichotomie de cette
espèce de paradoxe et moi je lance je
vous le dis clairement un appel à tous
les électeurs des républicains s'ils
veulent de la sécurité s'ils veulent
moins d'immigration s'ils veulent plus
de pouvoir d'achat et bien qu'il nous
rejoignent parce que c'est pas avec ce
parti qui est finalement devenu un
supplétif de la majorité présidentielle
qui le feront une opposition merci
Laurent merci beaucoup d'avoir
[Musique]